hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one of the absolutely key
distinctions that Emmanuel Kant makes
Not only in his work the proma to any
future metaphysics but throughout his
work is that between analytic and
synthetic and he first brings this up in
the Preamble on the peculiarities of all
metaphysical cognition in the proma and
he does so in section two concerning the
kind of cognition which alone can be
called metaphysical and why does he do
it at that point because he wants to
ultimately say what metaphysical
cognitions or judgments consistent what
kind are they and it's going to turn out
that they are synthetic a priori but
first we have to get clear about what
analytic and synthetic actually mean and
it it's tempting sometimes for people
who have been trained perhaps with other
uh philosophers in mind to say well you
know you got your analytic and and
that's sort of like what Kant is is
describing and there's nothing added to
the uh subject or terms or it you know
content and then you've got synthetic
and you know analytic is a priori or if
we want to use hume's terms relations of
ideas and synthetic is all experiential
you know ah posterior if we want to use
another term right and Kant is not doing
that Kant is introducing something that
he thinks is incredibly important the
synthetic a priori so what are these
basic you know
classifications now I want to point out
another thing too so here Kant is
talking about
judgments right but he'll also talk
about cognitions or concepts being
either analytic or synthetic and he'll
also in this very pre Preamble use the
term propositions or more literally
sentences set in German to describe them
as well and of course these are all
connected a proposition can express a
judgment a judgment can be a cognition
or an idea right so these are all not to
be opposed to each other I just want to
point out that Kant is not always using
the language of judgment as such but you
could say it's always lingering in the
background so what is the analytic he
tells us that analytic judgments are
explicative so they're you know just uh
telling you what something is a uh Laten
right they're they're not um adding
anything to the equation you might say
pun intended because we're going to be
talking about a mathematical example and
then synthetic ones are ampliative
erven um so they are taking us further
you could say how so so analytic
judgments add
nothing Nicks hun to the content the
inhalt of the cognition and I should
point out too that uses this term
content here uh for both of these the
synthetic actually increase Fair gross
and make bigger right the given
cognition they add something to it so
you know if we want to phrase it in our
own contemporary language analytic
judgments don't you know give us
anything new they do sometimes clarify
they explain right that's kind of good
synthetic actually adds something new to
what it is that we are talking about
thinking about making a judgment about
it now he'll explain this by saying
analytic judgments
Express nothing in the predicate now
what is a predicate so this is a little
bit of an old fashioned way of talking a
subject is the thing that we're saying
something about or judging something
about the predicate is what we are
saying or making a judgment about it so
you know for example he says if I say
all bodies are
extended I have not Amplified in the
least my concept subject of body but
I've only analyzed it that's why it's
analytic right as extension was really
thought to belong to that concept before
the Judgment was made though it was not
expressed so you know to to go back to
earlier thinkers you can say in analytic
judgments the predicate is already in
some way contained in the subject you
just don't
realize that it's there and by looking
at it more carefully you now bring that
to light and you're like aha now I see
right so he says that um on the other
hand this judgment some bodies have
weight contains in its predicate
something not actually thought in the
Universal concept of body it amplifies
my knowledge that's why it's a synthetic
judgment it it adds something to the
concept and so that's why we call it
that and then he goes on and he says
what's the common principle what what
these things are based upon of analytic
judgments and uh it's the principle of
what we sometimes call the principle of
contradiction or non-contradiction the
zat vooks vrook is contradiction in the
strongest sense and so ultimately we
should be able to trace all of these
back to the principle of of
noncontradiction and he says that all of
these depend wholly on that and are in
their nature because of that operary
cognitions whether the concepts that
Supply them with matter be empirical or
not for the predicate of an affirmative
analytic judgment is already thought in
the concept of the subject of which it
cannot be denied without contradiction
that's where the contradiction comes in
you're using the principle of of
non-contradiction a thing can not be you
know this and this in the same way at
the same time there's all sorts of
provisos um so you can say if if the
predicate really is contained in the
subject you can't deny it of the subject
you might not know it's there until you
look but that's how it works and so such
is the case of the judgments all bodies
are extended we just looked at that one
and no bodies are
unextended and he tells us that because
of this okay they're all a
priori uh even if they have
some Concepts that are empirical and so
he says take gold is a yellow metal now
this is what will lead by the way to
later thinkers who are using such terms
like The Logical positivist to say well
you know analytic judgments are not
necessarily like uh you know a priori as
in being the very nature of things and
we uncover them with our minds maybe
they're about language Kant doesn't say
that he's not worried about that at this
time but he says okay take gold as a
yellow metal I require no experience
beyond my concept of gold which contain
the thought that this body is yellow and
metal so the very concept of gold
includes those things that's what we
mean by gold okay so so far so good
that's analytic I think analytic
concepts judgments are easy to wrap her
head around what about synthetic so in
synthetic uh judgments again we're
adding something that isn't already
there it's not something just to be
unpacked from the given cognition or
materials that we're working with now
does this uh type of judgment have a
common principle some are going to
suggest that they are based on the
principle of uh sufficient
reason and he's going to say you know
synthetic judgments they require some
sort of different principle we have
synthetic a posterior judgments of
empirical origin but there's others
which are certain a priori which spring
from the pure understanding of reason
and they cannot possibly spring from the
principle of analysis namely the
principle of contradiction but require a
different one but this will still be sub
subject to the principle of
contradiction as he says um so you know
we're going to come back to that in just
a moment one candidate would be the
principle of sufficient reason Kant is
actually going to say that's not going
to work we need to find something better
than that now he's going to engage in
some
classification and so he starts out
talking first about judgments of
experience in this case right is
experience the things that we experience
in the world of sensibility or in our
own uh you know sort of Inner Space you
could say right which yields the laws of
empirical psychology he's just said a
little bit earlier so these are all a
posteriori by their very definition
because they're about experience
aposteriori means we did experience this
or somebody could experience it and he
says these are always synthetic it would
be absurd to base an analytic judgment
on experience because the concept
suffices for the purpose without
requiring any experience so a body is
extended not a judgment of experience um
but you know we can come up with all
sorts of other things coffee tastes
bitter but you add some cream to it and
now it's got sweetness right you you
can't actually deduce that a priori you
need to actually experience that out in
the world now we're not that interested
in that in the proma but what are we
really interested in the other two
classifications
mathematical judgments judgments that
are made within the discipline of
mathematics or about the objects of
mathematics we're going to talk about
this you know elsewhere in a bit more
fullness but what we want to get across
here he says mathematical judgments are
all synthetic and there's an important
Point here
he says this seems to have altogether
escaped the observation of those who
have analyzed human reason it seems
directly opposed to their conjectures
who does he have in mind there well Hume
of course who he will actually talk
about a little bit later on but also
libnet Renee deart these great
mathematicians who contributed to the
discipline itself you know maybe he'd
actually include Pascal in there as well
you know another great philosopher and
mathematician and they all assumed that
you know that mathematic stuff was
analytic and K saying it's not and he's
going to give you a number of uh reasons
for that he says that listen they're all
judgments a priori because they carry
with them necessity and then he uses the
example of 7 + 5 equal 12 uh he says it
might be first thought that this is a
mere analytic judgment following from
the concept of the PSM of seven and five
according to the principle of
contradiction and then he says that's
not really the case the concept of 12 is
by no means thought by merely thinking
of the combination of seven and five and
analyze this possible sum as we may we
shall not discover 12 in the concept we
must go beyond these concepts by calling
to our Aid some intuition corresponding
to one of them and Kant isn't
particularly interested at this point in
what intuition that exactly is could be
counting on her fingers it could be
something else but the point is
mathematics is actually synthetic now
does that mean that every single
proposition within the field that we
call mathematics is synthetic he says no
no I mean there's some that are analytic
but those are not really at the center
of uh mathematics same thing with
geometry by the way he says that um you
know there are some things that are
analytic and depend on the principle of
contradiction they only serve as a
method of concatenation like putting
things together not as principles so for
example a equals a the whole is greater
uh is equal to itself or a plus b is
greater than a the whole is greater than
its part and he says that um we use
these in mathematics we could think of
you know the transitive principle or you
know all all the different other things
that we might use and K is saying yeah
okay that's fine those are analytic
they're not at the core of what we're
doing in mathematics okay so far so good
what about the Third Kind metaphysical
judgments well this is where he has like
a whole discussion and you know it's
really what the the work itself is about
and he says metaphysical judgments
properly socalled because there's going
to be an an analog here to mathematical
judgments there are metaphysical
judgments that you know you could say
are analytic but that's because they're
not metaphysical judgments properly
so-called Ian they just happen to belong
as sort of like tools to metaphysics as
a science so he says we have to disting
distinguish the judgments belonging to
metaphysics from metaphysical judgments
properly so-called many of the former
analytic they only afford means to
metaphysical judgments which are the
whole aim the whole point of the science
and which are always
synthetic and then he's going to give us
some examples if there' be Concepts
belonging to metaphysics for example
substance which has been you know part
of metaphysics since Aristotle uh you
could say inaugurated the science I mean
we could say that it exists before
Aristotle but he's the the one who we
associate with the name metopus right so
uh he goes on and he says if there's
Concepts belonging to metaphysics the
judgments springing from simple analysis
also belong to metaphysics by means of
such analytic judgments we seem to
arrive at the definition of a concept
but as the analysis of a pure concept of
the understanding does not proceed in
any different manner from the dissection
of any other um you know even empirical
Concepts not belonging to metaphysics it
follows at the the concept indeed but
not the analytic judgment is properly
metaphysical the science has something
special and peculiar to itself in the
production of a priori now notice the
term here not judgments
cognitions which have to be
distinguished from the features it has
in common with other
rational knowledge and so he's going to
say listen metaphysics is concerned with
synthetic judgments a priori so is
mathematics for that matter we're going
to look at those in a bit more detail
there is one other thing that needs to
be mentioned and this is coming up in
the uh next section first and he says
that this is a remark on the general
division of judgments into analytic and
synthetic and he says you've got to make
this Division if you want to critique
human understanding um you've got to use
this this is why dogmatic philosophers
neglected this apparently obvious
distinction so wolf and balg garden came
to seek the proof of the principle of
sufficient reason in um uh the principle
of contradiction the principle of
sufficient reason if it indeed holds is
a uh synthetic a priori judge judgement
right so it would belong to metaphysics
you're not going to get it from Mere
analysis and then uh Kant says you know
in Lock's essay concerning the human
understanding I find an indication of my
division um and so he's finding you know
a predecessor there and then he says
that not even Hume really figured this
out um so you
know we're probably not going to be able
to use use the principle of sufficient
reason because that's part of
metaphysics we can't use that to figure
out first of all is metaphysics even
possible are you know AR priori uh
synthetic propositions possible we have
to figure that out on our own through
the transcendental philosophy which Kant
takes himself to be doing right and we
can't use a part of metaphysics to to
bootstrap our way into metaphysics but
we've got now the distinction between
analytic and syn synthetic something
that I think people often do find a bit
confusing when they're reading Kant
sometimes the explanations of it uh are
not all that helpful and can lead us
astray it's very important for Kant that
we get very clear about what these mean
right at the start of the proma so
hopefully this has actually clarified
those Notions in this distinction of the
kinds of content of judgments
propositions and uh COG nitions for
you